thank you
[Music]
do you know what the whole city bike
debacle now what's up with a city bike I
know people don't like them yeah yeah
something happened uh around a city bike
basically those City bike shows ones
that you just like swipe your card and
then you take it off the rack and go
biking here
um this is in New York this particular
situation uh but just without telling
you anything I'll just let you watch
what's going on
that's your bike
she's doing the Karen thing
please
camera
that's just my client guys
so take it
so defend yourself what's going on
I want to marry you I'm gonna give you a
chance to change your statement
so uh they're fighting oh dude they're
fighting over the city bike kind of um
basically that dude is saying that his
thing is swiped on there and she's
trying to take it yeah that's stealing
it was his account it's on the phone
right so when this first came out uh
everybody was like dude what a [__]
Karen whatever then they people
contacted her hospital and she's like a
nurse at or whatever and then they like
were like were aware that this is
happening and she's basically her life
is just in the dirt now from like what's
the real what she did what happened what
do you mean I'm sorry who did what who's
wronging who here's the thing here's the
thing they don't know yet oh based on
the video it really looks like she's
nuts oh no and that she's like trying to
Jack this bike but why like you know
it's a little weird
um
but the plot things because today they
like um the Lord she hired a lawyer and
the lawyer has shown that
her uh card was actually charged on that
bike oh really and yeah so like it shows
that there's there's a receipt there's a
receipt that it was indeed her card at
one point uh-huh and she's the lawyers
claiming that she paid for the bike and
then those guys came over and they
forcibly like pushed her back into the
stall so that it checked out and then um
and then it shows that uh it shows that
one of them tried to like pay for it or
something
and then it shows on her receipts that
she had gotten a different bike after
that because after that whole thing
stopped she still needed to get one so
she got it right off right yeah uh but
yeah it's interesting that now they are
showing receipts it could it could be
proven that it's [__] still no one
knows yet because it still has to go to
court but um she's trying to clear her
name because uh so that's that's like
the thing these days is like a video
could be taken so out of context and
everybody immediately jumps the gun and
says XYZ instead of being like okay well
there's a lot of information I don't
know yet right and then even this
development could be on Truth social
taking out of context yeah exactly I
don't know all it takes is one person
behind the camera or someone nearby
saying oh she fake crying right so
already yeah it's easy to just frame The
Narrative
the demeanors change it's like what
Trump does right yeah if people are
saying you're you're a nasty nasty woman
that's what people are saying I'm not
saying dude we're saying you know on top
of that even right so so another layer
to that is people that are skeptical
about these videos and they go wait you
know what I'm not going to say anything
until I know the full story those people
get called out for oh what yeah this
person is how dare you not believe you
believing the victim yeah for sure dude
I don't have those conversations I'll be
that person yeah so they're saying the
first receipt shows that the bike seen
in the video and they can confirm by you
can see the number on the bike it's um
it shows that that bike was paid for and
re-locked after just a minute
interesting so her story of like having
paper and then pushing that's the thing
is like they don't know if they really
did push it back in maybe she bought it
and then [__] up or just or walked
away right or decided to change your
mind who knows business cameras that
would be I'm sure there will be I'm sure
there will be nothing yet there's
another scenario yeah like she could
have just bought it and accidentally
like canceled it and she still thought
it was hers and the other guy thought it
was actually his because he
like why would they just randomly pick
this one person to like be bullied like
that that's kind of random you know yeah
it's all very clear on what they think
it has happening right could they all
possibly be acting like that's kind of
crazy too you know yeah I mean there's
that possibility too there's a lot of
different positives for sure I also feel
like depending on the situation though
too but like is is it worth it to get
into that much of a fuss just here you
take the bike I'll find another bike
that's the other like that's enough you
can always pull yourself out right right
on both ends too yeah yeah and then it's
just like now you don't even have to
deal with the situation because I think
like this this happened to my brother
um he was feeling
his Tower with air at the gas station
and he finally finished this lady Parks
right by him and walks around pulls the
the the what's it called the air
pressure too right and walks over to her
car but has the whole tube line laying
on his car and and Lance is like my
brother
um he's like hey like I don't mind you
taking the air but like you can't have
this on my car and her it was just like
an instant defensive like what the [__]
like oh I need it so like either you use
it and you have three minutes and then
he's like what he's like you don't have
power over me like what the hell this is
like this is insane and she instantly
went to pull out the phone and be like
oh this guy is harassing me
and that's the problem
narrative and he's just like
choices either just leave and like get
away from this crazy lady or like just
be like all right cool I'll wait here
all day and like have the cops come and
like well like you know it's just like
you've got to weigh your options yeah
because that's what you got to do you
gotta get ahead of the story first and
that's why your brother should have
pulled out his phone he [__] up right
so he doesn't have all these people who
are just like changing the story and
changing the context and just playing
into a character to help them be the
victim in the scenario because some
people will be like well it's her bite
first so she has every right to have
that bike and it's like yeah that's true
but would have been easier for her to
just be like hey bro there's [__]
eight dudes around me I think I think I
don't need to be here I need to remove
myself from a situation right now it
sucks because like it isn't just regular
people giving their context to like or
their opinions it's major high-profile
lawyers and big accounts that are
reposting these things as if it's like
objective fact and they're like look at
this another situation where a Karen is
confused but it's like like whoa that's
that's a little dangerous like you're
not just a normal person like you could
make a whole wave of people really yeah
making people think certain things and
that's pretty much the world and how
like polarized everybody is it's just it
generates more of that don't watch the
news man there were crowds though like
those like online classes like they'll
be like okay so a happen and then so you
have people that are like oh yeah you
know the the care and she sucks blah
blah blah and then someone one person
will go oh I found out that this is what
happened yeah yeah and then they'll all
jump oh my God
yeah and then another person go no no no
no no no this is the real story and
people just keep jumping and it's like
dude no one knows none of y'all were
there
shut up and just wait
get hurt are the ones that I had
for it when nobody knows the rules right
or the people that are getting canceled
for being in a comment box of this [__]
that's even more like who the [__] cares
about that
the dark side of the internet is like
you know know the finger pointing and
all that yeah but you know who will
always win is the person that posts the
platform like the platform yeah yeah you
always win that's true yeah there's no
reason for them to stop these people
from missing information or they're just
like whatever exactly like the Chinese
Zone Tick Tock yeah I think they're
doing great
nurse what sex is regardless of what's
true or what's not true and all that her
life is pretty much turned upside down
and then
she's probably calculating how long do I
have to weather the storm until people
forget and if she's single or if she has
friends she's she's gonna be triggered
every time she meets someone new or
they're going to recognize her right
that's why I think that ultimate
decision was to oh I see what's
happening here it's probably in my favor
to just walk away from the situation and
go find another bike yeah and that sucks
unfortunately you got to pull yourself
out if she if she is right yeah that
sucks and if the more that happens I
don't know if it happens a lot but for
me it really the stuff like that really
happens but when it does happen it's
like yeah you could just keep letting
them go but then now you're letting
people walk over you that yeah that's
true but it's also pick your battles
yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta always
pick your battles I learned on Tick Tock
for my MMA guy he goes I don't think
he's like a pro guy but he's just kind
of an instructor he tells people yeah I
can fight but I never fight because what
I don't know is is if that other person
has nothing to lose because then I'm
gonna also they're kind of like declared
as a weapon like at that point too and
it's just like you know that's true
you're putting yourself in a position
where you can really hurt somebody and
now you're liable for lawsuits and all
this other stuff but everyone also
thinks that they're owed something like
nobody owes you [__] yeah no a random
stranger doesn't owe you anything they
don't want to hear your explanation all
that [__] so sometimes it's just like
hey all right yeah if it's like stuff
over like bikes or like if it's the last
bike I get it yeah you know but even
then it's just like [__] here's a
picture of her this is her actual
receipt for the bike that's the number
on the bike in the foot yeah so it does
confirm that that exact bike she did pay
for or like it says zero because after a
minute it was already canceled right so
something definitely happened that's the
part they have to prove yeah they have
to prove what exactly happened between
the time per canceling yeah like yeah
how did this how did this occur because
it on her side of the story she's saying
she was forced to like let it canceled
on those dudes side I they were just
saying that she wasn't using it well on
his on his side he said in the video
that he's like no I have it confirmed on
my phone yeah well then it would be
really easy for him to also showcase the
proof right right so that's the thing he
probably does have proof that his
currently Maybe he's probably currently
signed into that bike in the footage
correct but she was signed into it prior
they don't know what happened to make
that switch so that's that's the the
point that's to figure out yeah that's
the mystery and what and either she's
lying still yeah or you know or those or
those dudes really did jackets yeah yeah
they both they both look bad
goes as far as getting a lawyer for this
one thing I mean she better be right
here
right for emotional damage she's gonna
lose her job too yeah
they're not gonna keep her I think
either way they're not gonna keep her
really I don't think so like the
criminal stuff okay all right let's take
that action of like your job it's like
you could be so good at your job but
because you have this description with
other people other citizens that now do
your job is on the line something that
you're maybe like because people went
after that hospital hardcore because her
logo was on the thing yeah okay let's
take the best what do you guys think
the wrong
yeah you think she's still she's she's
her Karen
you know what I know what that I don't
know I know that dancer
you guys understand why we always win
yeah
in reality I set up the Trap and then
can walked right into it you're like
your own guy
sorry I wanted them to answer
I wanted to say something crazy and then
we end the video here's the thing the
thing I don't know I don't know what it
is but one thing I do know is that
either way I don't think racism is a
factor in this [__] I think people are
Petty about the [__] and like two
Chinese guys will do the same yeah I
think racism is involved on on our end
the viewer end yeah yeah I don't know
the media situation unless unless you're
looking at it unless what really
happened was it's like you know the guys
were like hey yo this is this is
bullying this white girl right unless
that happens
and they had a selfie camera
or the reverse what the white girl was
like mess with these black dudes barring
those two extreme examples yeah I think
the racism is on on us it is that's true
that is
first degree
yeah that's intent bro yeah
[Music]
foreign